les doy la bienvenida a este programa de
cultura especial en France 24 sobre este
año de guerra en Ucrania quemado
saqueado o destruido Este es el triste
destino de muchos sitios culturales
ucranianos desde el comienzo de los
combates y de los bombardeos la primera
estrategia fue sacar de Ucrania las
obras que se podían mover y proteger lo
que se quedaba en el país A pesar de los
esfuerzos de la población la UNESCO la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas para
la cultura a las ciencias y la educación
registró que hasta el 22 de febrero de
2023 la invasión rusa dañó al menos
doscientos cuarenta y un sitios
ucranianos y es por esa inquietud que la
UNESCO tomó la decisión a finales de
enero de inscribir el centro histórico
de Odessa como patrimonio mundial en
peligro lo que reconoce su valor
universal excepcional
primero hay la dimensión simbólica decir
que esta ciudad pertenece al patrimonio
mundial nos concierne a todos todos
tenemos los ojos puestos en ella y
reconocemos su historia y su
contribución al patrimonio
luego hay una dimensión jurídica de
protección porque hay una convención
internacional de protección del
patrimonio mundial firmada por 194
estados miembros Y contiene la
obligación de los estados miembros de no
destruir deliberadamente el patrimonio
lo que supondría un incumplimiento de
sus propias obligaciones internacionales
están matando a nuestros ciudadanos
están dañando nuestro patrimonio
cultural lugares hogares Y quieren
seguir haciéndolo espero de verdad que
el paraguas de la UNESCO el escudo azul
pueda proteger al menos los cielos de
Odessa y a la propia odesa de estos
bárbaros ataques de los rusos durante
esta guerra
no solo el patrimonio está en peligro
por la guerra en Ucrania en 24 hemos
seguido desde el principio la situación
de los ucranianos y algunos llegaron al
taller de los artistas en el exilio en
París sus mil metros cuadrados sirven de
Refugio artistas de todo el mundo que
han huido de la guerra o de la
persecución desde el comienzo de la
inversión de Ucrania está asociación
acoge y colabora con artistas ucranianos
y rusos todos rechazan firmemente la
guerra lanzada por Vladimir Putin para
hablar de estos artistas en el exilio
tenemos con nosotros
directora de esta asociación francesa
Judith Muchas gracias por haber aceptado
nuestra invitación en cuatro un año
después del comienzo de la guerra en qué
ha cambiado su trabajo
Bueno desde hace un año tenemos una
demanda muy alta de adhesión al taller
principalmente de artistas ucranianos y
rusos Así que lo primero es una demanda
realmente grande y por lo tanto
obviamente Un aumento de la actividad a
la que tenemos que responder lo segundo
es que vemos que también ha habido
cambios en la llegada de rusos y
ucranianos por el camino gente que no
huye al mismo tiempo por las mismas
razones obviamente cuando finalmente Se
confirmó la movilización rusa hubo un
aumento de la demanda de hombres rusos
que intentaban escapar a toda costa de
la movilización y del lado ucraniano
podemos ver que ahora hay muchas
personas que han sido evacuadas por
ejemplo de maripol y que regresan a
Europa y en particular a Francia después
de haber pasado por Rusia y los Estados
bálticos Es realmente Una evolución en
el camino
En qué consiste de manera concreta la
ayuda que ustedes aportan a los artistas
ucranianos y rusos
entonces la ayuda se divide en varias
etapas en primer lugar están estas
líneas directas que abrimos
inmediatamente después de la invasión de
Ucrania las líneas directas hablan
directamente con los artistas que siguen
en su país de origen o en terceros
países y que intentan averiguar para los
ucranianos Cuáles son las posibilidades
de residencia y trabajo en Francia para
los rusos va un poco más allá porque hay
preguntas sobre los visados que no son
en absoluto las mismas del lado
ucraniano ya que sabemos que los
ucranianos se benefician de lo que se
llama protección temporal que es una ley
que se estableció en 2006 por Europa Así
que son cuestiones relativamente
técnicas Este es el primer paso la
segunda etapa es cuando estas personas
dan el paso y llegan a Francia cuando
consiguen obtener un visado para los
rusos o por parte de los ucranianos
cuando deciden trasladarse a Francia y
lo consiguen porque a veces es difícil
a su llegada estas personas vuelven a
ponerse en contacto con nosotros y
hacemos una especie de chequeo de su
situación es decir que necesitas como
podemos ayudarte a obtener un permiso de
residencia válido qué pasa con tu
vivienda qué pasa con tu posible deseo
de volver a estudiar qué actividad
profesional puedes ejercer aparte de
dedicarte a una actividad artística todo
lo que se necesita para un apoyo social
y profesional a menudo también se
plantea la cuestión de la asistencia
psicológica porque obviamente en ambos
lados estamos tratando con personas que
sufren traumas y es muy importante que
puedan hablar de ello algunas personas
lo hacen por Internet pero también
intentamos conseguir profesionales que
puedan ayudarles
como artistas rusos como va la
convivencia
va todo lo bien que podría ir sabiendo
que creo que para algunos ucranianos es
difícil concebir la cohabitación con los
rusos y para algunos no es concebible
para nada
por eso la mayoría de los artistas
ucranianos que recibimos son artistas
que hacen una distinción entre las
autoridades rusas y los artistas rusos
[Música]
hola no es el caso de todos los
ucranianos y de vez en cuando nos
topamos con comentarios despectivos
sobre el hecho de que ayudamos a los
rusos cuando No deberíamos hacerlo
e incluso les hicieron trabajar en un
proyecto común
como reacciona lo que estaba ocurriendo
organizamos un evento llamado stop Wars
que primero tomó la forma de una
exposición bastante breve y de un
concierto y después de todo nuestro
festival anual que es el festival visión
del exilio que organizamos
tradicionalmente en otoño
Así que les hicimos trabajar juntos Pero
como muchas otras nacionalidades ya que
aquí seguimos a 48 nacionalidades
diferentes con la idea de decir que la
cuestión de la guerra es una cuestión
universal y que había que cuestionarla a
nivel mundial en lugar de centrarse en
un solo conflicto
y así trabajaron en los mismos espacios
en los mismos proyectos y por nuestra
parte fue muy bien y creo que sus
respectivos puntos de vista también les
ayudan a ver las cosas de manera
diferente en ambos lados
y en nuestros locales ocurre lo mismo
tenemos talleres son los que rusos y
ucranianos conviven pero realmente de
forma física uno al lado del otro y va
bien
Judith Usted dijo al principio de la
guerra que no era el mismo exilio entre
los artistas ucranianos y los artistas
rusos Qué opina usted ahora un año
después
creo que hoy podría incluso matizar por
parte ucraniana en general nos
enfrentamos a una población que no se
considera exiliada en la medida en que
regresará su país lo antes posible salvó
las personas que han sido excluidas de
la sociedad por ser prorrusas o por
haber trabajado con rusos o por ser de
origen ruso Así que estas son personas a
las que les resultaría difícil entrar
porque no serán bien recibidas Así que
eso es lo primero por parte rusa estamos
en una ruptura yo diría más bien
ideológica y muy profunda
es decir
O sea
que decir que estamos en cese con
nuestro propio país sigue siendo una
decisión bastante fuerte y que creo que
desde el punto de vista identitario es
mucho más profunda porque de hecho
estamos diciendo que trazamos una línea
con lo que nos constituyó
intentamos reconstruirnos en otra parte
Así que creo que la diferencia está
realmente ahí
Muchas gracias por compartir este
análisis desde París como directora del
taller de los artistas en el exilio y
para terminar este programa especial
vamos justamente a mirar a los
testimonios de algunos artistas
ucranianos unos decidieron quedarse en
su tierra natal otros migrar siempre
intentando seguir con su arte y
reivindicando el fin del conflicto Alba
Santana nos cuenta sus historias
entre los artistas ucranianos en la
historia de los bailarines de United
ucranian vale es la más recurrente
la mayoría de ellos como en el caso de
smithco huyeron de Ucrania en los meses
posteriores al inicio de la guerra y
ahora el ballet es su forma de
resistencia
creo que cuando cantamos el himno
ucraniano En el escenario después de una
actuación es muy fuerte Porque todos
somos bailarines ucranianos haciendo una
cosa estamos luchando por nuestra
libertad a través del arte
además de la danza tienen otra Misión y
un sueño llevar la cultura ucraniana a
todo el mundo y hacer la perdurar en el
tiempo pase lo que pase
podría haber marchado totalmente pero
decidió vivir entre París tras la
invasión rusa Lilia litoxca diseñadora
de ropa vuelve todos los meses a la
capital ucraniana con sus patrones
diseños y su equipo de costureras este
artista de años optó por seguir creando
desde su tierra natal pese al peligro
Donde encuentro la inspiración para
crear una colección siempre digo que mi
inspiración es mi equipo que trabaja
bajo ataques masivos
la valentía y el trabajo incesante de
todo el equipo han tenido Su recompensa
pegadas a la máquina de coser trabajan
para mandar sus prendas para un evento
muy importante la semana de la moda de
París
desde el inicio de la guerra el destino
de los artistas ucranianos ha sido como
una lotería de lo más mundano hasta lo
más extraordinario
anatólfon filandra Era actor pero con el
inicio del conflicto dejó las cámaras y
los escenarios para enrolarse en el
ejército
muy
a mis compañeros les hizo mucha gracia
cuando se enteraron de mi profesión de
lo que hacía antes de la Guerra
sin embargo filandra pudo cambiar el
frente por las cámaras por cuatro días
para protagonizar el cortometraje Que
brille el sol y desaparezca la oscuridad
una historia de amor en tiempos de
guerra
mi objetivo con este proyecto es llamar
la atención sobre los militares sobre
los problemas que existen
[Música]
pero su objetivo a largo plazo es otro
como la mayoría de artistas ucranianos
aspira que la guerra termine y poder
retomar su vida con normalidad
Nos despedimos con las imágenes en el
Museo del Gran pale en París de la
exposición multimedia Ucrania un año de
resiliencia una cultura de resistencia
Gracias a ustedes por su confianza y
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en
Front 24 y 24 punto com
[Música]